[Music]
hello everyone
in this video we are going to start with
a new chapter on the forpal one common
plate theory
the plan is exactly like in the
development of the theory for beams
so first we had uh so back when uh
studying beams
we had developed first the theory for
the bending of beams and then we had
gone on
to uh study the buckling of beams
in exactly the same fashion in the
previous chapter on the classical plate
theory
we had developed our equations and we
had studied the bending of beams
oh sorry the bending of plates and in
this chapter we're going to develop a
theory
to study the buckling of plates through
this fobble one common plate theory
now uh i believe uh this is the
this is the first chapter which is
actually named
after uh two scientists august focal
and theodore pond carmen okay so before
we proceed
uh as a mark of respect and
as a nice historical recount let me just
briefly
uh mention a couple of things about them
so uh theorem one common uh
this is the same one common which we are
all familiar with from our undergraduate
studies on fluid mechanics
so probably you remember him from
[Music]
from the from the topic on
on the momentum integral equation or
perhaps
some studies on turbulence
however fopal uh fobble's name may be a
little bit
new to most of you
but it is very interesting to note that
ah
theorem one carman he did his phd
under ludwig prandtl and this is the
same prandtl we had again studied
in our undergraduate days while studying
the boundary layer theory
okay so many people do not know this but
ludwig prandtl uh in the initial days of
his career
uh had actually worked on elasticity
problems
in fact his own phd thesis
was on a problem involving a t-shaped
bar
on the on the tipping problem of a
d-shaped bar
where he had considered some issues
associated with its
elastic equilibrium and believe it or
not
the professor with whom ludwig prandtl
had done his phd thesis was none other
than
professor august popple here so in this
theory
you have actually a theory one common
and his basically what we can term as
his academic grandfather august popple
okay
uh so that's very nice so with this
brief historical recount uh let us get
to the actual business of developing the
equations of this four
one common plate theory it is also
important to note
that despite this this grand history
behind it
and this great gentleman who were behind
the development of this theory
there are certain issues with this plate
theory
okay now those issues are rather
sophisticated in nature so to even
understand those
issues you re you need a
uh a certain sophistication in your
in both your mathematical and your
physical understanding so
at these initial or preliminary days of
your studies of
of plate equations elasticity it is
probably not right for me to
to go into into those kinds of
issues uh rather let us try to first
learn these things
and as your brain matures more and more
you yourself realize
some of the issues um that are present
okay
so for now we just study it uh very much
as part of our syllabus
uh and please do not uh get disheartened
by the fact that there may be some
issues with this theory because
uh it is also very much true at the same
time that this fobble one common plate
theory
has been utilized to a great success in
uh in a wide range of very classical
engineering topics in actually building
uh things which are which are of immense
importance like submarine hulls
uh you can even re read about it in in a
wikipedia page
uh and very recently like relatively
very recently you know over the last 10
years
this formal one common plate theory uh
it has been utilized in a number of very
interesting physical problems
uh so it has its uh
its uses all right so uh just like we
have done in the case of beams
uh we are going to first start out with
the kinematical hypothesis
uh and we'll see that
uh as a slight twist on the kinematical
hypothesis that we had developed in the
context of
classical plate theory what you're going
to do here is to consider
uh a little bit of a of a modification
of that
okay so what we are going to say first
of all is that
well for our kinematical hypothesis
we still have these relations
so you can check uh the kinematical
hypothesis that we had used
in our classical plate theory
these are the same equations that we had
used back there
okay so here this u
is the deflection or the displacement
variable along the x direction
this by itself is a function of both x
and y
this v is the displacement variable
along the y direction
and it is also a function of just x and
y
uh sorry i should correct myself uh
the u s itself is a function of both x
and y the v
s is a function of both x and y the u
you can see
there is a dependence on z here the v
also it does have a dependence on z
okay so uh it's the w
which purely does not have any
dependence on
z okay it's a pure function of x and y
all right
so uh up to this point uh it is exactly
the same as classical plate theory but
the difference comes now when we
consider the strain components
okay so just like in beam theory when we
were considering
buckling uh we had to modify the
consideration of the strains by taking
the non-linear terms
in exactly the same fashion here too we
are going to
incorporate the non-linear terms but
before we can do that
we have to note something very very
important which we had done
back in in the buckling of beams also
we'll consider that this term
the del w del x that is going to be
significantly larger
than both del u del x
and del v del x furthermore
del w del y that is going to be larger
than del u del y and del v
del y now it is this place
actually where the where the problems
start the thing is
uh i mean what is the justification for
this why is it
appearing so this is actually i mean in
a in a rather funny way
it is attributed to the to the genius
of theodore von kamen uh
it said that like he was a hungarian
genius
he has said that so it must be true uh
so whether it is physically motivated or
mathematically motivated what what is
the magic behind it
well um uh let's not get into that but
we we recognize the fact that there is
an issue with
uh with saying things like this okay so
it's like this it it kind of works
uh but uh and it has been justified
to a certain extent but after a lot of
trouble
uh okay uh i i'm digressing uh
so let me get back to the derivation so
based on this uh
if we if we consider the the strains
okay and this will be the uh the
non-linear strains
so the expression
if we refer back to what we had studied
in the kinematics chapter
of our previous course on applied
elasticity uh
it's this
so this is the general expression
and because we have already said that
del w del x is going to be larger than
this other two terms
uh what basically happens is that this
expression
it approximately boils down to and if we
just substitute the expression for u
also from here
what we obtain is
del u s del x uh minus z
del square w del x square
plus so there is an approximation in
these first two terms the approximation
is in
dropping this one and this one and just
writing like this
all right next
for e y y
we have del v del y
plus half
del u del y square plus del v
del y square plus
del w del y square
[Music]
again that gives us del v s del y
minus z del square w del
y square so we are basically using this
expression now
and then we are going to drop this one
and this one based on this a primary
assumption
so we end up with just this
and please note that this is not really
an equal to rather it's an
approximation
next for e z
we have del w del z
plus half so this is the general
expression
del u del z whole square
plus del v del z whole square
plus del w
del z whole square
and please note that this w is a pure
function of x and y
so uh you don't have
well this term vanishes and this term
vanishes also
so this del u del z
uh well you can see from here that this
w del z
uh if you if you consider this del u s
del z that is going to give
us a zero because this u s is supposed
to be a
uh are assumed to be a pure function of
x and y so also this v s is a pure
function of x and y
so what this term this del u del z is
going to contribute
is just this minus del w del x but
there's a
whole square over it so we are going to
end up with half of
del w del x square
plus half of pro so from here
we we use this this del vs del z is 0
and this gives us minus del w del y
and that finally gives us del w
del y square all right
next uh
have for e x y
the general expression is
del u del y plus del v
del x plus
del u del x del u del y
so these are the um the quadratic terms
for this
shear strain
del v x del v del x del v del y
plus del w del x
del w del y
all right so we have to do this a little
bit more carefully
the del u del y uh
that is going to give us
del u s del y
minus z
del squared w del y del x
so that is from the expression of u this
v
is going to give us del v
del v s del x
minus z del square w
del x del y but you see
uh this term and this term is exactly
the same
so that can be simplified in the next
step
uh regarding
this term uh this
del u x del uh
del u x and uh multiplied with del u del
u del x multiplied by del u del y
uh well you see
if you just compare this del u del x
with this
del w del x so that part is much smaller
than that
and similarly this del u del y is much
smaller than delta q del y
so this entire term can be neglected
compared to this
in a similar fashion this del v del x is
much smaller than del w del x
and at the same time del v del y is much
smaller than del w del y
so this product is much smaller than
this product so this term
and this term they are negligible
compared to this
last term so what we have here is just
this
last term and of course instead of an
equal to we should put this as an
approximation
[Music]
okay so now
uh this gets simplified to del u s
del y plus del v s
del x minus y z
del square w del x del y
plus del w del x
del w del y okay
next for
e y z we have half
del v del z plus
del w del y
[Music]
plus
del u del y del u del set
plus del v del y
del v del z
plus del w del y
del w del z
now you see okay let me just deal with
these
these first two terms
from here i have
minus
del w del y
and from here it's just what it is
okay so this is going to cancel with
that but i have to be a little bit more
careful
uh even more careful now with these
terms because unlike what was happening
earlier
i cannot make a direct comparison with
uh as i was doing earlier
okay so you can see here i cannot make a
direct comparison between this term and
this term again i cannot directly say
that it is just negligible okay i have
to do a little bit of more work
okay so uh from here
this del u del y i obtain del
u s del y
minus z
del square w
del y del x that is multiplied
by uh and i'm going to simplify here a
little bit
so this u uh
so this is going to give me minus del w
del x okay
next for this del v del y i have
del v s
del y
[Music]
minus z
del square w del y square
[Music]
that multiplied by
minus delta w
del y and finally you note
that because w is a pure function of x
and y
this del w del z it is going to
contribute
to this being zero
okay so this cancels with this that last
term is zero
now what do we do with this okay
so here we have to argue you see
uh
even if we had not substituted this okay
even if we had not substituted this
uh this would have been a del u del y
okay this would have been a del u del y
and this would have been this
del v del y okay probably it would have
been simpler to just keep it like that
now uh we had earlier said
that the del w del x
is larger than
del u del x as well as
del v del x and del w del y
that is larger than del u del y and del
v del y
uh but i think it would have been
better if i had just said that this two
terms
this del w del x and the del w del y
uh they are of the same strength
okay so if it is true that del w del y
is significantly larger than del u del y
and del v del y it must also be true
that del
w del x is larger than del u del y
so we can neglect this term compared to
this
similarly we can neglect these two terms
compared to this
okay so it is as if that they are
of the same kind of strength and these
four terms they are of the same kind of
strength so whenever we are directly
comparing with
any one of these with any two of this uh
it is the left hand side terms which are
going to be dominant
okay so in that sense
uh this term is going to dominate over
this entire thing i might as well
have not substituted here that would
have been clearer but anyway i have
written it
uh this term would have would be larger
than this
okay so uh
overall what we are going to get here is
that
this is a very small term this is a very
small term
this also uh is a small term
so if we just
check up on the previous page uh
you will see that
we are keeping terms which are of this
strength
which are of this strength but
uh suppose if this term or this term
where to be multiplied with something
small then
uh it would have been pointless to keep
that okay
and now just just maybe pause you
pause the video here a little bit and
think about it it's
saying something like this that suppose
this entire entire two terms it is of
strength
let's say 0.1 we keep that
however if that itself gets multiplied
with another term which is
let's say which is which is small
like again 0.1 then
the multiplication of the product of
that with that
would be very small it would be of 0.01
so in that sense what we are going to do
now
is to say that this particular
combination this particular product that
is going to be negligible
again this particular product that is
going to be negligible so overall what
we're going to say is that
this is going to be neglected
and set to zero all right
okay now next we considered
the e zx
so we're going to proceed in exactly the
same fashion
uh
[Music]
for e zx we have half
del w del x plus
del u del z
plus
del u del z del u
del x plus
del v del z
del v del x plus
del w del z del w
del x
[Music]
till w del x remains as it is
for this del u del z of we end up
with minus
del w del x so that cancels with that
and this uh del u del z
that gets uh replaced by
minus
del w del x and this
del u del x that is going to give us
del u s
del x minus z
del square w del x square
next is del v del z that is going to
give us
minus del w del y
multiplied with
del vs del x
minus z
del square w del x
del y and this last term
because we have the presence of this
delta delta that is going to contribute
a 0. so exactly following the same kind
of arguments that we had
now we had made for the e ey z
term uh we are going to say that this
particular product
is uh negligible again this particular
product
is going to be negligible so overall
this is zero all right
now what we have finally then is
the e axis which is like this and please
note
that here this first term and this last
term
they are independent of
z similarly this e y y here
we have this first term and this third
term they are independent of z
and this e z that is independent
of z okay so
uh can we perhaps write this
in a somewhat simpler fashion
so just notationally what we can do is
[Music]
um
and this we are going to use throughout
we are going to write our e x x
as e x x
naught minus z
del square w del x square
let me write that z a little bit better
so you see what i have done here is uh
within that e x naught okay so you
understand that within that e x
x naught i have
uh kept these two terms that u s del x
plus half del w
del x square so you can just check
here so this first term and this last
term that i have captured within that
e x x naught in a similar fashion for
for for this one i'll capture this del v
s del y
plus half del w del y square within a y
y naught
so e y y
that will be e y y
naught minus z
del square w
delta y square where
the e y y naught is equal to
[Music]
del v s del y
plus half del w
del y whole square
and the e x y
let's see what we can do about it here
uh sorry i've missed this bracket here
uh
this e x y again this term this term and
this last term
and they are independent of z and this
is
not so what we are going to write this
as
uh is
e x y naught minus z
del square w del x del y
and please just note quickly what we
have done here is that this half cancels
with this two so i just have this minus
z del squared w del x
del y
and here this e x y naught
is equal to del u s del y
plus del v s del
x plus del w
del x del w del y
with a half in front of everything
all right so
[Music]
so overall uh let's see what we have
uh what we have accomplished here uh
we have written down these terms uh in a
form
where the z dependence has been isolated
but uh so all and also this e zx
has been set up
for following our assumptions
we have managed to approximate that to
be equal to zero
now
[Music]
what about these terms
this e z up it contains within it
the uh del w del x square and the del w
del y square
uh so it's something like this
that in this e x x term
we have the presence of this but we do
not neglect it
you see it is very much present in that
e x x naught
it is this term is very much present
similarly in the e why why not this term
is very much
present so we directly cannot say that
we can
that we are allowed to neglect these
sort of terms
okay for the e z said
but you note that uh i have not directly
written in
in this final recount this e z set
okay so what is going on here
uh well you see the e z
that does remain uh non-zero
but just as in the classical plate
theory
where we had forcibly taken the sigma zz
to be zero here also will do such a
thing
so when we finally go on to uh to the to
the application of the virtual work
equation
as a first step towards the derivation
of the governing equations
we are going to set out by saying that
the sigma zz
is going to be equal to zero and because
the sigma says it
would have gotten multiplied by the e z
so even though e z by itself is not zero
but the contribution
to the to the to all the terms because
we we assume that sigma z is equal to
zero
that that doesn't really contribute okay
so
uh ultimately what we are going to uh
to play around with is this e x x this e
y and this e x y
okay and the whole game will be around
these terms
all right so now this was about the
kinematical hypothesis
and is as you can see it is certainly
more involved in the classical plate
theory
and also the corresponding version in
the
in the buckling of beams okay on that
note i'll
end this video and in the next one i'll
start with the application
of the virtual work equation all right
thank you very much